[Music]
what's going on guys I just saw John
Wick chapter 2 and uh it kicked butt you
know what else kicks butt we got the
directors of the original John Wick to
come into studio and give us their
honest reactions to our honest trailer
of John Wick check it out here we are
with the directors of John Wick and so
much more exciting stuff we'll talk
about a little bit but chadki and David
Leech thank you so much for coming thank
you thank big fans big fans
fans ready to get roasted well it's yeah
we're always a little bit worried cuz we
Honest Trailers we have to be honest but
I think we were pretty nice on this one
yeah honest doesn't mean being an
[__] honest means just honest could
be good all these years not knowing that
so you had said have you so you have
seen a trailers before was there one you
actually saw like we're always curious
cuz we don't we sit in our little bubble
like you have seen we watch it all the
time in fact pretty much right and
direct based on not getting
roasted how how many times we were on
set going
those us it's a puppy we're
screwed don't match God no one's going
to count this yeah no we we think of you
guys a lot so huge fans yeah we watch
them we watch them a lot yeah you guys
obviously huge stunt backgrounds history
and some amazing films like and this was
sort of the big feature film that you
guys got to do was this what was it
about this film and what tell me about
sort of getting there and making the
choice to make John Wick well I think we
had been offered a lot of different
projects anything from like Navy Seal
Seal Team Six Delta one anything with
blood in the title we pretty much got
offered blood fist blood shot blood
thing blood shot
eyes so you're looking lot of sequels
like two lot of sequels got a lot
anything with a two or actually we
weren't even lucky enough to get a two
anything with a four or six we so we
were just looking for some we had you
know ideas on action are slightly
different it's not just blowing stuff up
it was trying to create a cool world and
how to tie in different types of action
to like World creation just you know
where can we have more fun with it then
just do the bu the numbers action film
and we had known Keanu since the The
Matrix trilogy and he came to us with
this script uh John Wick and when we
read it it was the guy didn't talk for
what like 20 Pages he didn't say a word
and we're like oh serg leion this is
awesome and then I think the original
body count in the original John wi was
like six not even maybe two it was
really little it was a really good
template to sort of apply the type of
action we wanted to do and actually
apply a world so I mean when it
originally you know it had it had these
World building elements and then we it
was very realistic it was grounded it
was more grounded and we expanded on it
and sort of added sort of this sort of
fantasy element to it that um you know
that that we like and so we tried to
make a graphic noveles and it it's one
of those perfect scripts where you read
it and it's like it had great framework
and we just could put in whatever we
wanted and build the world how we wanted
like it had the gold coins but very
different thing we like oh well this is
we just took Greek mythology like oh
this is a Talisman this is it the river
sticks okay under all that like
Subterranean world that you know most
mythological Tales have well I missed
that I just thought this is cool okay I
got we're going toing it back in we also
thought like you know when you look at
some of these action scripts and you're
you're put in a box of like what price
you can make it for it was all physical
action and we can do that I mean we do
that in our cars are expensive yeah and
like it was like how do we and then how
do we make that physical action jump and
there's like this we were playing with
the idea of gun fu for a long time and
funny it's still called
gunu people passed on it we offered it
to Big directors like Hey we're doing to
do the same kind of chph but it just
takes a lot of prep it takes the actor
willing to commit basically to learn
ballet with that and then longer takes
mean a higher body count so you can't
like empty hands is one thing but when
you shoot somebody twice in the head he
he doesn't get back up so it's hard to
do a protracted you know or an elongated
piece of choreography we didn't checked
did you reuse a bunch of stunk guys a oh
my God let me we can tell you secrets on
the we call it dribling we call it
dribling so when the camera p off guy
that that dude gets up and runs as fast
as he can behind camera put on put on a
you see head changes and you'll see
every first you can tell how you know we
shoot out of order sometimes in film you
always tell which which scenes you shoot
first the guys have long hair and beards
it's always the first scene they'll
shoot and then we start shaving and you
get go teas and you get the mustache
then the guys with completely shaved
heads and clean faces that's like John
Wick to there a Mir the uh Museum
sequence cuz everybody's like shaved
heads no facial hair you know run out of
stun at that point
start doesn't see this we we milk our
stunt team for it's all these be movie
we you know coming up we worked on a lot
of B movies and you know cut our teeth
like directing second unit on these like
lower budget action films and then
obviously working into big budget action
films but the um you learn all those
tricks like you only got five guys okay
how do you make them look like 10 how do
you make them look like 20 lot of wigs
man
makeup and hair and costume become your
best friend the scene start getting
darker and darker well I'm curious cuz
you know the I think that the born
movies for what especially what Paul
Greengrass took over like they brought
something new to action film making but
I think that a lot of people took the
wrong lessons from it and all action
suddenly became closeup and and and
choppy shaky Cam and day job was doing
this movie kind of an offshoot of like
you guys wanted to bring back cuz that's
what I love about both of these movies
is the action is shot phenetically and
energetically but you can you can see
what's happening you can see thatu and
and everyone else learned the moves and
that it's you can appreciate what's
going on but it's still exciting was any
of this kind of like we want to go back
to that we yeah it was I mean we're huge
fans of uh Martial Arts Cinema and Asian
Cinema and I think that that's always in
our DNA to let emulate Jackie or Jet and
those movies like you just hold the
frame because the performance is good
you don't need to hide anything you just
want to see great performance and so
when you can get an actor to do it and
you can train him to do it it's
compelling and I think in the first
Matrix Chad doubled Keanu and I remember
when he came back he's like I'm telling
you they're making a Hong Kong movie and
a big Hollywood budget and we're all
like I no way and when that thing came
out we're like want to see that it's
just done a process you know I mean when
green grass did it it was to infuse
tension to make you feel oh tense of I
think that was very well done and then
after that it became a way to hide
things hide the stunt double hide the
wire hide the stuff true do what we're
doing the shoot is very simple you you
stay wide you track back but the only
thing is the process you got to get an
actor you got to train him because it
starts with a guy right without keano
being as good as he is we can't shoot
that way we can't edit that way editing
should be a choice not a forced call
because you you have to cut around
things that's what it and that's usually
the trick when you shoot second unit
action is sometimes you don't get the
cast you got to shoot everything with
the doubles and then you got to piece it
together our was just like in the
beginning we're like okay we're making a
commitment everybody's going to come to
rehearsals DP is going to have to hide
the lights cuz we're shooting wide you
know electrician is going to have to
hide the cables K's doing it we're going
to choose our own edits we'll edit when
we feel like it needs more things but
everybody nut up cuz like we're going to
shoot there's no B camera there's no
we're not cutting out of this so when
you get the whole crew on board with it
action we go and you're you're in and
out of it in just a few takes cuz you're
doing a lot of rehearsals obviously to
get this already but like how many
what's the average length of takes you
have to do per big Action Shot you know
so are you are you together enough that
it does go pretty quick if we I think we
are doing between 5 and 10 like the club
scene and stuff you're dealing with like
300 extras so as long as you don't get a
bad wipe or a bad extra across you a bad
acting or some guy looking right in the
camera which is usually Thing by the
time you get there other than the exas
the camera guys have rehearsed the stun
guys have rehearsed and the lead cast is
a keo's rehearsed so that we got that
it's just kind of dialing it in so it's
more about creatively improving things
than trying to oh my God we got to shoot
we got to shoot it's really the dance
it's often times you know if the method
Works where kean's trained up the wazo
he doesn't miss the stunt guy have been
doing it forever there are you know
there there are contemporaries in the
business they don't miss it's really
about making sure that the camera and
the choreography is working the
aesthetic it's really that's what's fun
about shooting that way like you have
people that can just do it it's like
having you have option you can make you
can worry about like not just getting
the action okay we got the okay that's
good but like we want to make it look
pretty like in front of the screen or in
front of stuff or the lighting you know
we want to see the sets we're big fans
of the old bonds so when you went to St
meritz or the Alps or the Bahamas like
you got transported there and you can't
do that if you're on a 200 mil going
like this we want you to see and
geographically understand the scene and
see the location and go holy wow this is
a cool place like where does this
nightclub exist where does this bath
house exist in Tribeca we wanted to show
you cool places then and you know shoot
people in a in a face face yeah like the
murderous in honestly it's just
like he did there was a lot of people
died in that yeah I mean we just want to
make basically it's a musical we we take
the same approach as a live performance
or a musical and that's really the
method we use I mean it sounds wacky but
it's absolutely true I mean for this I
mean we're also St musical I think I
think by the way it's going to happen
now we want a pie 30 million doll
opening it's going to happen yep musical
off waybe start small and then go big to
ice capades John M the cartoon I mean
come on can you imagine them spin around
you you were going to pitch that oh yeah
yeah I mean toe pick toe pick Ice
capades come on Benelli 12 gauge shotgun
and some
toix uh well look I think we should get
to the trailer now now that we've
buttered you up
nice but uh if we want to put our put
our cans on as ke I always say it's cans
can just can my faite favorite lion
speed from piano um uh we can watch the
trailer and will obviously if you want
to pause at any point and put us a task
please do we'll do the same uh but we'll
play it up here and let's do this all
right very requested very highly
requested trailer we waiting for the
sequel
again they they stole his car they
killed his dog now he's going to kill 76
people work for the dad of the kid who
did
it John
Wick so the you're say you're disputing
the body count it's a little higher than
that yeah it's like 83 we went off of
what Lion's Gate gave us yeah don't
don't believe that they came they came
in after we made the movie Lion gate
wants to skew it for
publicity you have to defend the dog cuz
I feel like that's the thing I don't no
no no no we I feel like that's the one
you made it so visceral that I'm like
they killed his damn dog from his dead
wife like you know it's a film curse to
kill a dog and we had to defend it to
the studio absolutely they were not it
wasn't we didn't have a studio yet but
we had defend it to the producers hard
pitch but for the audience that's like a
blank check though for anything Keanu
does to the rest of the movie it's like
it doesn't matter what he does kill them
all we we didn't quite know that we got
halfway through post going oh Jesus
Christ we killed the puppy it's like
how kill a fish like they kill goldfish
that's we that's an overreaction but the
dog was like yeah John Wick the whole
tank
of all right we all agree so we're just
it's Justified for the sleeper hit of
2014 that your friends would not shut up
about combining the non-nonsense Revenge
movies of the past with the slick
production techniques of today in an
action flick that doesn't rely on Quick
Cuts or shaky cam I didn't even know you
were allowed to do that how's Li n going
to hop a fence in the next take in this
this is 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
18 now that's clearly to hide things yes
or is it also to keep the sort of the
ftic energy up like how do we justify
I'm going to go with energy on that one
I don't know what they were trying to
hide I they crossed the line yeah they
crossed the line at one point they
crossed the line and they went back and
forth forgot something went back to the
other side went and had lunch and that
would have taken a while yes it's very
Noir yeah but that can you shoot a sh a
shot like that quickly or what you do
like in second unit world you put
multiple cameras on it all the time so
you give the director the chance to you
know direct it in in editorial but then
they went nuts I mean three Camas we try
to give them like choices not like use
every single May stuck maybe he got his
pants ripped I don't know what you're
doing I don't know do you see ker being
able to do this long into his Liam n in
years you know and his what climb a
fence like that I think any of us could
climb a fence like that like that
especially if we can cut around he
climbed
it he did fall they could have lowered
him down on a crane and dropped him I
don't know um yeah totally ke kid yeah
he's pretty he's pretty handy mamal
pretty ageless right yeah
great man that must have taken them a
while I mean seriously that was like 14
different camera angles me John the man
whose mere name makes criminals
reconsider their life choices stole John
Wick's car oh John Wick
oh witness keo's eighth and arguably
best character named John he's a retired
Hitman tragically in love with a video
clip but after the world's most
oppressing crime days after his wife
died pause for a second who are all
these friends who are all these people
well no it is it's all Helen's family
yeah it's her family she she's a you
know she's an award-winning photographer
and artist oh that's her back
story know he was a hitman we like to
think there were hints of a past and you
know he may or may not have come clean
as you can tell we like amb ambigu yeah
okay interesting she but they clearly
had money because we've learned it would
be pretty expensive to get a puppy
dropped off like that yeah yeah did you
I swear to God I just just adopted two
puppies from China no worries and a lot
people call [__] on that swear to
God they time it right to the freal wow
wow wow they really do puppy delivery
service you get puppy passports and all
we we really did we researched wow no
way now I don't know if they time like
on my death do that okay we took a
little yeah but she could have someone
to make sure
they you know upon my death 24 hours
deliver to husband May Cry best train
puppy ever yeah will one of your enemies
like a really hard to manage pet yeah a
bunch of sugar gliders I ever one are
those things called sea monkeys Just Add
Water I love that all right let's keep
going my die you steal his car and kill
his dog he'll turn the entire world into
a game of Call of Duty on the easiest
difficulty to quote the man
himself enter a mysterious does he ever
say wo he does not not we went out of
our way to we have a lot but the O's are
an O to wo it was very conscious to go
oh that and I think Michael nyquest is
fourth language
English uh no he he's Swedish so between
Russi learning Russian and Swedish he
had you know there's a couple different
line choices in there and we went with o
cuz it was really o very simple and it
was kind of and we couldn't have K go wo
so we had him go o yeah John Wick
wouldn't say w whoo there's nothing in
the world would impress but everybody
else around could go like who they would
say who in life does he owe a lot or wo
a lot or electric guitar or anything you
know that's a good uh you know he really
doesn't no like like as a dude like no
yeah he's like H there's a lot of that
but really right yeah like yeah like
there's a lot
of did you ever mess up a take and then
Point Break the the gun into the
air I don't know we don't record on
this I want possible deniability on
let's just say that we got some great
outakes yeah we love the homage of that
in Hot Fuzz yes
we're huge
fans let's keep
going enter a mysterious Shadow Society
of Assassins where everyone is way too
casual about dead bodies hey
John you uh working again can I ask you
a
question I've always been curious about
that is that just like a friend of is he
an assassin inside the police force is
that just a friend of his who's like uh
on the inside if you notice in either of
the John Wick they don't kill Innocents
they don't kill cops they don't it's
completely hidden it's within their own
business so as long as they maintain
that the cops are
coolm is like so you were this was all
planted for there was a franchise in the
in the head not a franchise just we we
tried to define the world really really
clean like no there's not dirty cops
it's just they're in the no we're in the
no it's good the cops have their own
world which maybe we'll explore in joh
Wick 19 yeah but they have their own
underworld as well and he would be part
of that yeah and Jimmy would be part of
it but there's a mutual respect there
all right well the next question queing
Spencer up oh are we talking about yeah
how much is a coin worth it seems like
one coin gets you either like a night at
a hotel or a drink at the bar coins and
quarter coins and good question we use
them more as business cards like you
can't get access to the club like if if
you only have if you're worried about
what a coin costs you know you got to
ask the price yeah you're not you
shouldn't go eat at the restaurant
that's a cool way to when you go to the
hotel a coin just symbol is like I'm in
the no you know I'm in the no so that's
worth it could be worth it's point of
entry so it could be worth a meal could
be worth a drink it could be worth
access into the club if you worri about
counting coins and the fact that he's
giving away for drinks proves he has he
does not care he's earned his place yeah
so it's it's it's influx you you don't
get change yeah she doesn't hand yeah
there's no there's no change that but
there is no currency value and when you
guys were creatively we never we never
played it that way it's more like you
know if you imagine there's a large tab
at the Continental you just you know
it's more of a custom and it's more of
an access point and they're like
collecting but they're like keeping it
tally well we learn too he's sort of
building the currency too uh M Shan it's
part of the World Part ofation the
Continental owners help control they're
the he's making the big
tab so wow we kind of thought about it
I'll accept that works for me yeah all
right there you go cool keep going see
Cleanup Crew Hotel ball
Healthcare car service and assassin jazz
band are they
assassins no but they would not hesitate
to hit you with the
cello um couple things like David
Patrick Kelly the guy who plays Charlie
at the body first work with him way back
on the crow oh wow and he actually
walked into an audition with Dave and I
like doing that we're like what do you
what just you're hired what do you even
walk why audition he actually came in in
the whole hat in the deal we're like
What uh David it's Chad you know we work
together on the crow and I was like uh
just stop you're hired just take off the
hat you're good and we have another
Matrix reference which is Randall duck
Kim in there he just plays a doctor he
was the keymaker on the
second and he lives in New Jersey so
without Dave and I spent a lot of time
with him on the Matrix trilogy so we're
like want to come in and be a doctor
stitch up he was awesome yeah he's we
love our cast he's such a good
dude uh so well here comes our joke but
I wonder did any of these ever come up
is
Assassin of establish that we went
the
Craigslist is there more Brewing as far
as I mean of more thing more secret
society things coming there's definitely
we had stuff even before we started the
second one we had Dave and I had
notebooks like I mean yeah it's just you
know as stunt guys we're on the road so
much and you're in hotels pretty much
all the time so it kind of comes like
what you know what do we need we need to
rent cars a really we need to get food
we need to get Healthcare you need to
get you need okay you got to buy your
guns you know you gotta go to the gym
you gotta find like so we just kind of
took that attitude and went okay you
know you gotta have a cool concierge and
you got all stuff in gym like do they
have CrossFit do they do they have it in
the video game I don't know if you've
seen the 3D the virtual reality game the
r for we got to the training center is
you go underneath we got to play a test
level we didn't do the whole thing you
the roof the roof is the sniper but they
have a they actually have a
gym cool you go back and do it it's way
there's no push-ups and pull-ups oh no
you you just got to curl
[Laughter]
um no it's awesome 9 mm 45 38 can you
throw dumbbells at people shuriken
oh dumbbell on dumbbell tra you guys are
yeah I've never in a
gym this is an assassin gym of
course cool let's keep going watch as
John hunts down Theon Greyjoy who's gone
from literally so was he cat you seen
Game of Thrones I really hadn't seen it
Dave is the one that got me hooked you
watch it now I know I do but like before
weie hadn't seen it so we watched like
one episodes with Alfie and it was
tricky cuz like that was you kill a
puppy cool now you got to kill a kid
little tricky so we wanted somebody that
just absolutely looked like a prick from
the
beginning and by the way he's absolutely
not a prick in real
life we Skyped with him and he was the
nicest kid and he kind of he just went I
think he was at a pool party when we
scraped him he's at a party and he got
he like hey I just got and he was so the
nicest kid and then he's like can I give
you a little bit of a a go yeah I give
it a go and he just went into dick
mode was awesome dve was like you know
what this guy's great and he was such I
mean he was game for anything I mean you
know young guys running through a
nightclub pretty much just in a towel
right he oh he did way they did way
worse to him in Game of Thrones oh
that's what see I didn't know that I
like and you were giving us about
putting you in a towel and you nervous
yeah had your weenie
C you know like Extreme as a guess right
yeah another bottle like oh God he get
sucker punched don't get me a bottle in
breathtaking action sequences where John
kills countless actual red shirts
culminating is that that aoo that was a
Star Trek reference you got to put the
red shirt if you see a red shirt in you
know what's coming yeah I've also
wondered cuz Keanu has that thing like
in the second you see a little bit with
like in motion there like is that is
that a him thing or is that like an
actual tactical thing of like the
sideways and the you know like he's
always doing that the street that you
weren't supposed to hold your we do it's
called like a press it just makes it
look AGG we want it to look super super
aggressive like it was it's not just
pivoting which would be more tactical
because you keep the sights right there
but just to go kind of like you cuz it
is it's very like his examing but then
when he does that you're like oh sh we
just kind of we wanted it to feel a
little bit more kinetic and a little bit
more like oh like he's stabbing him
where he's punching with the gun it was
like a little action design thing we do
just to make
it it gives it the con that's cool where
he casually shoots the person who's been
hunting
then wrestles an old and out of shap
rushing dad in a ray all right to run
out of money at the end so yeah we we
had talked to you about this actually I
was like tell me the one thing sort of
and that I mean it makes sense because
you sort of it's hard to keep the the
the level of intensity I guess going
throughout the film so is that was that
that is true we you need an action
setpiece for the end uh you know third
act every movie struggles action movie
struggles and uh we're just you know
fight scenes are honestly cheap so it's
like he's going to fight vgo and we're
like how we going to justify ran out of
cars was there a bigger Invision that
you had that didn't get to happen oh
much bigger yeah what was the alternate
is there a bigger Showdown we would we
could have seen we wanted to do a little
bit more of a gunfight between it's just
hard cuz like Michael he did a great job
don't get us wrong he's great but like
sometimes it's weird because we wanted
an older cast member that had a little
bit more gravatas and we love Michael
and um you know Girl With Dragon Tattoo
so we kind of brought him in that way
it's just when you get to the the
physical like keo's been training since
the first major since since he's in his
20s right so it's hard to make a
believability thing like especially just
watch John Wick kill x amount of
people and then you're like how do you
make this work and we had a [__] John
a little bit and then we're like you
know what let's just do theur kirawa
thing or Leon thing let's make it more
visual we'll make it a showdown put it
in the rain which rain is a whole
another story after that cuz it was
literally shut down 33° and their fire
department was going to shut us down cuz
the pipes were freezing and N Nest was
shaking K was shaking wearing a warm
tent going one
more uh but yeah it's always a trick
like David saying it's like you know you
don't have money you don't have time you
like you know so cool in John Wick 2
when he got like a like Commons
character and stuff he was starting to
get adversaries that could match him
blow for blow so yeah just uh we Tred to
you know like you can always do the good
guy against the one bad guy or we take
what we like to do is divide him up so
he's got a couple adversar never just
the bad guy or the the head henchmen
there's a couple of cool henchmen so you
can do different varying like Styles or
different kind of action set pieces and
it feels like there's a chance a good
guy may lose cuz like it's hard I don't
think you think John Wick is going to
lose when he goes up against vgo you're
like more bullets boy that was dumb you
should have just shot him John Wick was
out of bullets I'm surprised no one
called us on that right no more bullets
why why shoot them we're like we thought
oh my God they're going to get us for
this this is personal yeah so that's
we're going to honest trailer ourselves
and go should have shot shot him had a
whole gun yeah yeah I mean there's you
know there are edited versions of this
we played with like where he just walks
up
and he shoots him there's one and then
there's another version where he does
it's like the first move he just like
Wham in the neck and then they have
their dialogue and it was it was
powerful too but then you just kind of
it's such a set piece of action and the
whole movie you just kind of needed a
little more so we put the fight back in
yeah it gives you something to make fun
of us for yeah thank you still fun and
we like and we love we love the rain and
we we just like looks visual
storytellers honestly it was a big thing
just to like can we make an artistic
action movie or at least what we
consider an artistic action movie and
putting him in a tank at the end would
kind of undercut
that why be warm and comfortable you
know we have an alter take we like we at
least put him in a robot suit or
something put in a robot suit all right
where's the spaceship in
time no that's every Marvel movie we
work
on oh my God
third we thought about it we just
couldn't afford
it huh kind of feels like they blew
their budget in that nightclub
scene to the kosad as this Immortal
50-year-old still kicks just as much ass
as he did in his 20s and finally loses
the trademark chill he's been building
up since Bill and Ted are you
can't as we pray that Keo pull off PA
for a second this movie does so much to
subvert action movie cliches and tropes
and stuff like that but they really do
the all right guys you take care
leave the building you you don't shoot
him just make it nice and slow slow
while I leave the building we did have
assume everything goes to
plan we had the doctor we had a way
around Dr Evil but we didn't have the
location we got that location like 3
days before we shot there was a
Williamsburg Bank in Williamsburg yeah
and it was beautiful location but we're
like it's really big how we going to get
them out like if we start a fighting it
the bad guy would spend the entire fight
scene walking I'm leaving now I'm on my
way out uh what do you say we just go
you know what enough I'm annoyed I can't
be bothered so we went Dr Evil on us
just like you know but we didn't have
sharks with laser beams it was fine but
yeah that that was the one that stood up
for me too but I when they're when it's
fun enough you don't care so you had
built up enough equity and the audience
to allow to have have that kind of knew
that was coming and when in doubt get
William to fall on a rooftop need right
sniper solves everything snip I like
sniper rifle through stained glass
window like I don't even know how he
sees like I
he's
got that good he is he's good especially
with that like 1911 s I think that's the
only rifle we had in New York that
looked like a sniper rifle oh rough prop
budget y you guys would be great at
making Honest Trailers tell we watch it
all the
time sometimes our motto is cool over
rides you know it's true though logic we
did like it looks cool we're going to
shoot that well right and like we were
saying I think it's you you just got to
earn it you earn those passes if the if
you're having a good time or really big
sound effect either
one what he's never done before follow
up a great action movie with a sequel
that doesn't suck you have
many your conscious you remain tell
Concord we were debating how much to
show and we how long do we keep this
Artic
moment
for we were there when they shot that
were
right
here pause can you explain what he's
saying there's nine matrixes right yeah
uh yeah no you guys didn't get it good
answer come on it's so simple completely
understand scrip remainder you got to
you know the program you got a
remainder ke when he fell
asleep it's actually a
cardboard I mean we love Matrix I love I
no that's not I love Parts have reloaded
a lot yeah yeah
amazing revolutions but yeah that's the
Harvard of film schools I mean look at
any any of the department has it came
through those sequels from us to the
production designers the VFX guys
everyone's doing really really well I
mean they're incredibly demanding
taskmasters yeah and I would say they're
absolute Geniuses absolutely I love
speeder everyone gives them
we months of our life unbelievable
unbelievably fun and the stuff you learn
yeah they push it they push the edge for
sure yeah we'll give them much credit
for that did you guys do the fight
scenes for Speed Racer we did you think
was in it you played a couple parts in
it did you think your career was going
to lead up to John Goodman fighting a
ninja um by the way you should see the
St of that what it's not a nin it's a
what it's a nanja it's a nanja n right
it's a nanja it's a nanja um we had fun
with the guys in Berlin the stunt team
in Berlin and we choreographed it and
we' shot video vid of it before and then
uh John Goodman quite the character I
think it's online you can find it yeah
you can see the behind scenes behind the
scenes of it Dave was the Viking in one
of the things it was awesome yeah we all
we been a viking yeah you come from the
stunt whe you can [__] yourself out you
just uh lot of cameos I think I I died
in Ninja Assassin too like 17 times love
that yeah uh starring section I know gun
fu to friend or to foe head
shots kale kale R this was tough all the
like head Quint Tarantino style where
you're like oh that guy's badass what's
his name we love love uh learn that
fromis character casting Wist Church
kill Super shredder in Ninja Turtles
2 wow this movie is like 80% head shot A
Dog's Purpose I thought it was like 87%
head shot man John so good at shooting
he doesn't even shoot vertical
video that's pretty good that made me
laugh last night
his wife's a
photographer a little bit more into the
world now WID screen yeah this was hard
for us because we really enjoyed the
film and Kudos again because it really
does earn it's uh earns the little
little imperfections or continuity
issues it doesn't matter because it's a
lot of fun but uh John way 2 I do want
to touch upon like what so what was it
like sort of doing that because we we're
going to do that next I'd love some
insight now and people have seen it just
to give us a little bit like making a
sequel has to be a little daunting yeah
oh my God it's yeah incredibly daunting
daunting I mean we did something kind of
cool we just made a movie that we
thought we wanted to see a little genre
thing I mean honestly we had both taken
second unit jobs after we wrapped John
wck going oh well that was a good go no
way Wow Let's uh let's continue on with
our day jobs yeah kind of kind of messed
that one up didn't we um but no and it
people kind of liked it so we kind of
went like that and I think people like
the World building in it and honestly I
mean that movie with anybody but Keanu
would have been a yeah it just wouldn't
have been the same the empathy how you
can't it's hard to find an action cast
member that's GNA cry over a puppy fight
in his boxer shorts yeah that you're
going to give that you're going to give
a sh and it's like so you know it's like
you know it's funny is chowski they used
to when we went back for the second uh
Matrix like for loaded like what's up
and they're like uh we're like what's
going on it's like well it's a curse of
the sequel and it's like it's m you you
like we want to go back we want we love
the world we love working with Keon we
love our crew we love the action it's
just like how do you be original it's
always the same thing familiar but
original so how do you be original when
everyone's already seen it so you can go
bigger better faster stronger or you can
go deeper or you can just remake the
movie again and we figured well don't
want to remake it bigger better fast
that's always the best we'll go a little
bigger a little bit we'll go deeper into
the world and try yeah but like I mean
God what was it it was a months before
we had a what John Wick rescuing a girl
he had a daughter yeah we had a lot of a
lot of story ideas on the table and look
it was always hard to find the emotional
buyin that was ever going to be stronger
than what we created let me say you only
get one puppy a career did you ever
consider just shooting the dog over and
over again each time he adopts a pu it's
like the James Bond thing of like every
cold open is his pet you know there's
the boring thing where you still can't
remember you still can't remember he
still was a puppy he keeps getting new
puppies but they keep dying the shelter
just locks out new wife she dies of
cancer yeah yeah I mean you know just
unlucky it's like bman Robins yeah
exactly stop giving him kids we were
Prett we we skipped over all the Robins
the wives the kids went right to puppy
so you really can't bet like what so you
kill a couple wives a couple girlfriends
it's not going to do it so you're just
going to have to ride had him do you had
other Alters where he was just going
after the oh my God love interest and
other things and Winston di did you zoom
ahead at any point when in the creative
like we're not going to start right
after it left was there yeah we talked
about that we talked about prequels we
talked about yeah everything and then
you know this kind of rose at the top
like World
expansion and running on the fumes of
the original that people L we just
actually honestly we did like the honest
Trail like what do we hate like we hate
when it cuts it 5 years later we're like
let's just have it the next day like
John's having a really bad week you know
as soon as he gets back he's like woo
that was a close one I got my car back
and then we we're going to put these
guns away again put up this nice
concrete job and then the doorbell love
he cleans it all
up we're we're big into that cus
interruptus the doorbell he always hangs
up on people like John like you already
know so we're just kind of jumping ahead
with never complains he just like that's
a lot of work to go reement the basement
and if you notice there's no Uber in our
world like he's got a walk although
there might be in
three
assassin we discovered something right
John leamo actually runs an Uber service
a lot of good I think Argyle and die
hard a lot of good character you can
have drivers I mean you know if you ever
go to New York is so full like what a
wacky culture New York City is there's
so much you can dig deep on and that's
where we got the homeless stuff is like
you see so many like any one of them
could be anything the garbage collectors
the street musicians everything he was
so rich so we just had to go into that
and that's kind of how we so do you see
this going as long as it feels right I
mean or do you see this as a Trilogy is
there any sort of insight you know what
we're pretty happy with the way it came
out like again I can't tell you how cool
it is to work with Keanu I mean the
coolest guy ever hardest working guy
ever I mean you just can't beat him but
like look if people like it we're happy
it's a fun world for us you know do we
want to do other things of course does K
want to do of course we just like the
guy it's kind of a cool thing and it
lets us do whatever we want with action
so it's like you know and we there's car
porn there's action porn there's gun
porn we call it all our different porns
and it's fun to go into that world the
attention to detail and there's no
limits for us as long as we keep it
somewhat grounded and believable it's
it's fun so yeah I mean you know it's
not a if that's the worst thing that
happened to our careers it's not a
totally bad thing I think they'll be a
three yeah I think so did pretty well
you want to see it yeah we'll see
you can't leave us with a cliffhanger
like that my favorite part of John 2 we
were cuz we were laughing but in the in
the best way fun but it's like that
moment where he and common are walking
through the
subway so great it's a it's the facials
ke's
making they all thought it was
ridiculous too when you shot it oh yeah
we all thought like just like we just
like just do it and just just go for it
okay probably like the third weirdest
thing people in New York see on a DA
well that's funny we got that idea cuz
honestly we were scouting the new PA
system with under the Freedom Tower and
it's so funny we were walking down I
think one of the guys on a location
scout I think it was one of our grips
tripped in front of all these people and
instead of helping the poor guy we just
walked right over him right FR like it
never like it never happened like I to
help the poor guy up and like well okay
well well jeez and we even joke we like
you have a gunfight here no one give a
and we're like plus they're such good
shots that it's not like they hit
anybody else can't kill any innocent in
or each other in that scene that was the
other thing like I
when once again some things are
cool go with cool first Fair uh well
great I we thank you so much for this
we're gonna we're going to take you over
to news do a little bit more sort of a
couple more questions from fans and
stuff any final questions from you three
uh don't stop making films yes thank you
s that was like a hand job question
these are really cool might as well
finish it off yeah I I love great action
and you don't get a lot you don't get a
lot of great action movies now and and
that's why these movies are so cool is
you know you guys are doing us a big
favor too can we call them out on stuff
call us out on stuff call our directors
out and stuff because honestly doing
good action is not rocket science it's
taking the right amount of time and like
the new trend is Story Action Story
Action like what anybody great like peek
andp frankenheimer Leone any of those
guys of course action is just part of
the story you know if you prep three
weeks for a dialog scene prep three
weeks for an action scene ain't that
hard right yeah we don't we don't get
that in our in the world you know as
choreographers and as second unit
directors you don't get the time and you
wonder why the stuff doesn't feel the
same way I mean two different directors
yeah it's a priority you know that's
true like one John Wick action scene
tells you more about him than him going
I wasn't always an assassin you tell you
about you're probably wondering how I
got
here so that's it keep calling us out
man I want to see I want to see the
impossible task prequel yeah we oh yes
we to we're still talking might be a
viral video oh yeah could be a behind
the scenes
or I tell you get ke here put it to him
yeah let's put it out there to him all
thank you guys so much keep up uh keep
at it we love it we're big fans we will
keep you honest uh just keep delivering
the goods we love it thank you thank you
well that was a good time thanks again
to Chad and Dave for coming in and
talking about the honest trailer for
John Wick did you see John Wick chapter
2 what' you think tell us in the
comments below we want to know I want to
thank you for watching screen junk I'm
how rnck hit me up on Twitter
bye-bye hey guys did you know that this
end card works with your phone now I
know right click the boxes below to
watch more screen junkies videos and
click the screen junkies logo to
subscribe and get this show Honest
Trailers movie fights and more